good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video contains many updates about sports
and art which are supposed to be
opposites but as we shall see today that
dichotomy like so many dichotomies is a
lie also for reasons that will soon
become clear I have to wear a lot of
shirts today so Hank as previously noted
I'm auctioning off my support in the
World Cup this year which is why I
recently acquired gear from all 32
nations participating in the tournament
basically if you go to the link in the
doobly-doo you can essentially purchase
my love on behalf of the country of your
choice and your donation will be 100%
tax deductible provided that you live in
the United States this isn't seriously
our uniform is it I don't feel like I'm
about to play world-class soccer I feel
like I'm a six-year-old dressed for
Thanksgiving dinner so to date this
crazy plan has raised nearly $6,000 for
nerdfighters charity the foundation to
decrease worldsuck but starting today
all proceeds are going to benefit
sarcoma research sarcoma is the kind of
cancer that Augustus waters has in The
Fault in Our Stars it's also a cancer
that lots of actual people have in real
life and it sucks and I hate it so we're
gonna raise some money to fight sarcoma
here's the deal every time you donate
one dollar I will donate three so your
dollar is essentially worth four dollars
and I will support the team of your
choice in the World Cup and I will be
the most committed fan in the world
unless someone else pays me more like
hey guys it's fans I'll be supporting
the Ivory Coast when they play Colombia
and to prepare myself I have already
learned several songs about cocoa Torre
kono Colo Colo right no singing okay but
maybe you like your soccer slightly less
professional Hank remember a nerdfighter
uses advertising proceeds from a FIFA
video series to sponsor an actual
professional football team that fights
homophobia and racism and is owned by
its fans right well nerdfighteria
sponsored AFC wimbledon finished this
season in 20th avoiding relegation from
the fourth year of English football
huzzah meanwhile the fictional AFC
wimbledon wimbly Wobblies led by ball
john green other John Green Seb brown
and Yaya bomba are putting together a
great season pic I suddenly realize how
weird this must all sound to new
nerdfighters and also to old
nerdfighters really just to anyone come
to think of it I mean the movie version
of my book is coming out in ten days and
I spend most of my free time worrying
about the health and well-being of FIFA
14 players who are technically made out
of ones and zeros although to be fair so
is the movie okay maybe you like games
but you don't like soccer by the way I
think this is Argentina but it doesn't
show up well in this light anyway oh
there's an amazing nerdfighter minecraft
server called nerd craft area that also
raises money to decrease worldsuck
check it out
at last let's move on to art so Sara's
new show the art assignment is going
great there's a new assignment up from
the brilliant and fascinating artist
Kate Gilmore and if you like talking
about and/or making art you will find a
thriving community over at the art
assignment where people are making
everything from like gifts to sculptures
what else is going on
all right the nerdfighter kiva group
that dedicated band of suck decree sirs
is very very close to 4 million dollars
in total loans to entrepreneurs in the
developing world so in case you don't
know about Kiva you choose a business
person to support you can make a loan
for as little as $25 and then they pay
you back over time and if you've ever
tried it before your first loan is free
it's hard to believe we've almost made
four million dollars in loans and of
course like there's also scishow space
which has a great community of space
nerds thinking and talking about our big
and beautiful and terrifying universe
and lastly nerdfighters new community
ambassador valley 27 seventy-six has
created an amazing map and calendar of
upcoming events and gatherings who you
have a point John yes I have two points
first look how many shirts I can wear in
a single video secondly even within the
tiny world of nerdfighteria there are
lots of ways to connect by a nerdfighter
gatherings or if you love art via the
art assignment or if you love terrible
FIFA playing via the Wimbley Wombles I
make at least for me the best
connections aren't just about feeling
less alone they're about finding ways to
look at the universe more broadly and
enthusiastically whether it's
contemporary art that takes you there or
soccer or building worlds and minecraft
or learning about space or working with
entrepreneurs around the world or
whatever it's great to feel alive to the
world for me it's less about what you
like than it is about how you like it
like I'm not a huge fan of boxing but
the poet Richard Kotova says and he once
wrote that to him
boxing serves as a modeled lends unto
the bifurcated human heart who's one
true nature is to break apart Hank I'd
like to think the human heart has more
than one true nature but regardless
here's my question for you nerdfighters
what's your lens these days I get about
we're all 32 shirts at a video vibe but
I still Hank I will see you on Friday